I'm excited for folks to see the
performances both of the actors that
they know and they're familiar with but
also we have so many new actors that are
in the film wakanda forever has massive
shoes to fill after the success of the
first black panther film they had to
overcome challenges like not knowing how
to swim difficult costume designs
intense choreography and of course the
loss of one of the most beloved
characters
together we ended up using those
feelings to create something really
special number one tenochuerta admits he
didn't know how to swim he definitely
needed some swimming lessons before
taking on his role of nemour one of the
most important things about his
character is natural swimming ability
when the director Ryan coogler often to
ouch the role he just sort of omitted
that he couldn't swim I replied that I
had never drowned and went back to my
managers we just say yes and then go see
what's up the actor ended up doing eight
months of swimming lessons which is
definitely apparent on screen
number two this cast is truly like a
little family when talking about Ryan
coogler's directing process nobody ever
actually felt directed or instructed I
feel like we're together like in the
kitchen cooking up the thing it was a
very collaborative process and everyone
got to have a say into what their
character's motivations were it gave
everyone a sense of ownership over the
creation of their characters and it also
allows you to come in and say but I
think I see done what about this and
this and this number three let's talk
about one of the most dreaded costume
pieces
obviously spent a lot of time in the
water showing off his Newfound swimming
skills but what came with that were a
pair of really tiny swim shorts
they're little little shorts
yeah they inevitably developed the name
of Shame shorts honestly I I can't
recommend this for Halloween because
he's he's frozen out there number four
one of the most important factors in the
movie the film stalock and cast includes
Mexican actor Mabel Karena who plays no
More's cousin and Venezuelan actor Alex
livinali is the warrior atuma
tenochuerta even learned the Mayan
language Mabel Cadena was positively
overwhelmed by the indigenous
representation this movie fought for to
me it's crazy because I can find in the
movie the little things from my Mexican
culture number five some of the most
intense underwater training imaginable
the actors spent eight hours filming a
day in a large water tank they trained
with Colombian national record holder
Alex linas an instructor with free
diving instructors International Alex
livinale explained we trained for months
the first time I was there for like 30
seconds but as the time went on I was
there for like three minutes relaxing
number six
Leticia Wright had a special bond with
Chadwick Boseman Leticia was Chadwick's
favorite doctor to work with so Ryan
coogler knew that in order to honor him
it would be important to elevate her
character one of the things Ryan took
note of was Chad's smile off camera as
himself his smile was huge like a
Cheshire Cat but when he was on screen
his demeanor was a lot more serious she
was the only actor who would get who
would get him the small ass child on
South Side man he broke character number
seven intense action movies can make for
some pretty scary stunt work Leticia
Wright suffered a pretty severe injury
involving a motorcycle
it's centered to the hospital with a
fractured shoulder and a concussion she
was shooting a chase scene that put her
on a biscuit rig which allowed the
camera to shoot her while riding in a
real environment the rig ended up
clipping a median and it shifted the
bike off causing it to take a pretty
severe tumble with Leticia still on it
she told variety I'm still processing it
I'm still working through it in therapy
it was really traumatic production had
to be paused for two months while she
recovered number eight not the most
common thing to design costume designer
Ruth e Carter had to do extensive tests
on the costumes designed for the movie
in order to make sure they would hold up
and retain form underwater the team had
never worked with underwater costumes
before so this posed a whole new set of
challenges for the water scenes we had a
20-foot tank in which we did tests
divers went down in the water and I had
to put them in costumes that included
headdresses and capes just to see what
those costumes would do in the water and
I ended up putting weights in number
nine did you notice shuri's Adidas
they were actually Hollow and made from
a new 4D technology the company is
launching soon at first they only sent
them one sneaker but they ended up
convincing Adidas to create enough shoes
for the motorcycle stunt when you go
outside of our industry they're going
what do you mean you need two two we
need two we need ten
number 10 rewriting a script without
your main character is no easy task the
script for wakanda forever was already
completed when Chadwick Boseman passed
away so unfortunately they were forced
to create a totally different story Ryan
coogler thanks his phenomenal team when
it came to recreating the story in honor
of Chad when making the first film the
bond they developed was really that of a
family so Ryan knew exactly how to write
everyone's motivations and voices I had
a good idea of what folks would be
willing to do and not willing to do
these all very strong
minded people when it came down to it he
really just wanted to honor Chad as well
as keeping the Integrity of the film
whether it was a journey of of grief and
loss that we were navigating as we as we
did this to honor our brother number 11
the music in this film speaks volumes
the task was to find an artist that
could meet them thematically where the
film was at enter Rihanna Ryan thought
that because Rihanna had had recently
become a mother she would actually be
more inclined to create a track for the
film motherhood is a massive theme and
Motif in this in this film and it was
incredible at the timed out multiple
people from all over the world
contributed to this song including tens
an artist from Nigeria Rihanna put our
touch on it and we finally heard it I
was moved and then she said y'all did it
for Chad number 12. the crew really did
their research the wakandans wearing
white to King t'challa's funeral is
based on Ghanaian tradition when
designing the hundreds of funeral
costumes Ruth e Carter ended up taking
inspiration from several cultures
throughout Africa to create a unique
identity for each wakandan tribe you
could actually identify all the tribes
even though they were all in white but
the white unified them in tribute to the
Ascension of Chadwick Boseman
number 13. there are only a few things
Ryan coogler shares in the early
versions of the script before Chadwick
boseman's passing King t'challa was in
mourning for the time he lost between
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers end
game one of the big themes in the script
was grief which is still a huge theme of
the current film but in a different way
Ryan coogler talked to inverse about his
thought process the character was going
to be grieving the loss of time you know
coming back after being gone for five
years
as a man with so much responsibility to
so many coming back after a forced
five-year absence that's what the film
was tackling number 14 the water posed a
major challenge for this cast most of
the cast was not comfortable in the
water Ryan coogler explains the sphere
of water as one of the impositions of
Black Culture a lot of us have we're
ready to have fear of water you know I
myself had the same thing going on most
everyone in the cast including Ryan had
to learn how to swim or at least improve
their swimming skills Lupita Nyong'o
actually took it upon herself to train
by holding her breath underwater and
carrying heavy weights she would send
Ryan videos of her workouts on her days
off let's just say coogler was shocked
and impressed nothing we'd asked her to
do by the way we were like what is this
lady doing she was so intent on being
believably comfortable in the water she
wanted to be as much of an expert as
possible
number 15 this was the fault of
scheduling conflicts
Daniel kaluya had to miss out on being
in wakanda forever because of his
commitment to Jordan peele's movie nope
he ended up having to keep it a major
secret because he didn't want there to
be any spoilers he also wanted to
protect fans from disappointment
in this film dedicated to Chadwick
Boseman the cast and crew did not
disappoint when honoring his legacy
overcoming production challenges and
learning dangerous new skills to bring
wakanda forever to life what was your
favorite behind the scenes moment